Welcome back to State of the Union.
This Friday is the two year
anniversary of the January 6th attacks.
The events of that day led to criminal
prosecute actions
and played a role,
pretty big one in the midterm elections.
They also changed the careers of two
House Republicans
who chose to serve
on the January six committee
and largely
as a result of that patriotic service.
They both are now leaving Congress.
Joining me now is the outgoing
Republican congressman
of Illinois, Adam Kinzinger.
Thank you so much for joining me.
I really appreciate it.
Let's start with the work
that you've been doing over the past
almost two years,
the January six committee.
It's over
and it's
now in the hands
of the Justice Department.
Do you think that President Trump
ultimately will be charged for crime?
Look, I mean, when I got into this,
when we started this process,
I didn't know, you know,
I'm not a lawyer,
not a Justice Department guy,
didn't necessarily know
is he guilty of a crime or not?
Obviously, what he did
from a presidential perspective,
from an oath perspective as a problem
as we've gotten into this.
I look and I'm like, yeah,
if this is not a crime,
I don't know what is.
If if a president
can incite an insurrection
and not be held accountable,
then really there's
no limit to what a president can do
or can't do.
And so, yeah, I do think
ultimately when we get to
where we're going to go,
I think the Justice Department
will do the right thing.
I think he will be charged.
And I frankly think he should be.
I mean,
everything we've uncovered
from what he did
with the Justice Department
to everything
leading up to January six
to on January six,
sitting there for 180 minutes
and watching this occur
in the hope that maybe, just maybe,
that last attempt
to stay in power will work.
So he should be charged and convicted.
So that's my personal opinion.
It's not from a
from a lawyer
just what you've been collecting. Yes.
And it appears like I look at that
and I go, if he is not guilty of a crime,
then I frankly fear
for the
future of this country,
because now
every future president can say,
hey, here's
the bar
and the bar is
do everything you can to stay in power.
You talk about the future of this country
as you are
on your way out
and leaving Congress behind.
Are you optimistic
or fearful for American democracy?
Well, that's a tough question.
So typically, I'm always optimistic.
I try to be
you can't do this job if you're not.
I'm a little fearful in the short term.
You know,
we are in a moment
where facts don't really matter.
What matters to people
is just what
your opinion is
and the facts
that that comport to that matter.
We're in a
we're in a moment
where about half
the country believes there
that the election was stolen.
Maybe a third of the country now believes
the election was stolen.
But if you're in a democracy,
and you believe
that your vote doesn't count,
that's dangerous.
So in the short term,
I'm a little pessimistic,
but I am in the long term,
very optimistic for this country
because I look back at trends
I look back at rough times
we have been in
and we've always come out
and we haven't just come out of them.
We've come out stronger.
Democracies are not defined by bad days.
We're defined by
how we come out of those bad days.
And so in the long term, I am optimistic.
But I got to say to people,
this is not a moment to rest.
This is a moment
where you have to understand
there have to be uncomfortable
alliances to defend democracy.
But we can do this.
If you had a Wayback Machine
and could go back a couple of years
and tell the Congressman Adam
Kinzinger of
I don't know what the
just the 2020 election,
what you would be doing
for the two years following
would you say yeah go for it.
Would you have done anything differently.
You know,
it's a great question
because I get asked a lot like you know
would you have done it differently.
Obviously there's
been some sacrifice and everything in it.
I wouldn't do one thing differently.
Look, I
you know
the way
this is kind of gone
in the last couple of years.
It's been tough, right.
You know, I've had
an extended family
that sent me letters
telling me
that was working on behalf of Satan.
I mean, that's not something
I could have imagined.
Have your family say there.
Yeah.
I mean, it's
nothing I could have imagined,
you know, a couple of years ago.
But what that does to me is it
reminds me of
just how bad of a place we've gotten to.
And, you know, everybody in their life.
And I was no different
when I was a young guy.
You know,
you always imagine
a moment where you can stand alone
and where you're like the one person that
that can do the right thing in a crowd.
Right. Everybody imagines this moment.
Very few people
get a chance to actually do that.
And I've learned in this job
that very few of those
that get the chance actually do it.
I feel honored to have
been at this moment in history
and to have done the right thing.
You know,
my kids are going to be proud of it.
That's something
that I take very seriously.
And now I want to do anything different
when Congress is sworn in.
And two days.
You're getting a little emotional.
Just a little. Yeah.
This is tough for you. Yeah.
I think it's it's
so I'm not going to miss the job.
I'm glad I'm not going to be back.
It gives me time to focus on
broader things. Bigger fights.
But it is like,
you know, thinking of Adam Kinzinger
when he's 32 kind of the new freshman,
you know,
kind of like optimistic and bright eyed
to where we are today.
It's it's an emotional thing
because it's 12 years of my life. Right.
And you know I got into this single now
I'm married with a kid
so I can think about that legacy.
It's been a heck of a ride.
Sure has.
I was going to ask
if you are going to be sad
not to be part of the next Congress
in a couple of days.
No, I won't.
Look, I
you know, it's
I want to
still be able to have an opinion right.
So that's going to be tough is,
I think, adjusting to the fact
that people
will have less interest
in what you have to say.
But it's a tough time
in Congress right now.
I mean,
it is
I'm looking at what
this is shaping out to be.
And I know the tough things
we have gone through in the past.
This is going to be a really tough year.
What does it say
about the future of your party,
the Republican Party,
that Marjorie Taylor Greene
and people like her are kind of ascendant
and the Adam Kinzinger and Liz
Cheney's of the world are
no longer in the in the Congress.
I think it says to me
that the Republican Party
is not the future of this country
unless it corrects. Right.
Unless there's a change.
Because I got to tell you,
if you think of a successful America
in 20 years,
that's not going to be an America
based on what Marjorie
Taylor Greene wants
or based on what
some of these radicals want.
The only way this country can succeed
is if we learn to work together.
We once called Kevin McCarthy
a true friend. Yeah.
If you could sit him down.
Just the two of you right now,
what would you say?
I just let him know I'm disappointed.
Right.
I mean, he has he as a leader,
not just a member of Congress,
as a leader of Congress,
he had an opportunity
to tell the truth, the American people.
And he went to Mar a Lago
a couple of weeks after January six
and resurrected Donald Trump.
He is the reason Donald
Trump is still a factor.
He is the reason that
some of the crazy elements
of the House still exist.
If he didn't go down there.
You think Trump would have a nice out?
I do. I do.
I think I think, first off,
how do we actually remove
Trump from office during impeachment?
That would have been huge.
Right so that's on McConnell
and some of the Republicans
in the Senate.
But yeah,
I think the second because I lived it
the second
Kevin McCarthy went to Mar a Lago,
the conference split from like quiet.
What are we going to do?
Where are we going to go to?
Begrudgingly defending
Donald Trump again.
He is responsible, actually.
Donald Trump
should consider Kevin McCarthy
his best friend
because Donald Trump is alive
today politically
because of Kevin McCarthy.
Last year
you told the Huffington Post
you would love to go up against
Trump in the 2024 primary
You said, quote, I think it'd be fun.
It would be fun.
Are you going to run for president?
No, that's not my intention. No.
But it would be fun to run against him
because he stands up and just lies.
He tells untruths.
People love it because it's entertaining.
But eventually
people have a concern for their country.
So, no,
my intention is not to run in 2024,
but it would be fun.
It would
be fun
to stand on a stage with Donald Trump
and actually tell the truth, because
when he's on a stage, it's
nothing but lies that come out.
Well,
no matter what you do,
I don't think that this is the last
that we're here.
If we're going to hear
from Adam Kinzinger,
thank you so much and thank you
for your service.
You're obviously also in the
in the military.
So thank you for that
and everything
that you've done in Congress as well.
You bet. Thank you.